guess what we're going to do
marker
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to protect the american hamburger
for you that's right what i do is i talk
about
obsessively the regional american
hamburger
are you shooting
today we're gonna take a deep dive into
the chili burger
what i love about the american chili
burger is that it's
made from beef and when you add beef to
beef
that's right you get more beef
the chili burger also adds some spice to
it you have some spice
um yeah [ __ ] it's gonna be a problem now
um i don't want you making that much
noise chili
it's a good chili though this is always
the first sign of insanity when you're
talking to your food
born in l.a the chili burger has a very
deep history
earliest records show that the first
person to put beef chili on a burger was
a guy named thomas deforest in 1920s
thomas owned a popular 24-hour chili
partner in los angeles called tomaine
tommies
back then leftover burger beef from the
previous day became chilly
thomas used two different ladle sizes to
serve chili a larger size label was for
bowls of chili
while the smaller ladle was used for
topping chili on an open-faced hamburger
a new shorthand emerged since the cooks
called the smaller ladle
hamburger size the burger with chili was
eventually named simply
size it's hard to imagine but chili was
one of the first burger toppings
even predating cheese by a few years
this is the story of america's first
chili burger there are many different
types of chili burgers out there
one of my personal favorites though is
the hyper regional north carolina
slaw burger what i like about this
burger is that it has
obviously a beef chili and on top of
that is a
mayo-based coleslaw and when the
coleslaw mayo
combines with the chili whoa that's a
hell of a topping
ew what's wrong yeah you ready
let's do it first thing we have to do is
make coleslaw so to make chili sorry
that's chili
to make coleslaw you need a food
processor or you can slice it by hand if
you want but this is much more fun
you also need some carrots we've got
some carrots here
and you also need some coleslaw [ __ ] oh
no
cabbage into the food processor
okay
[Music]
there we go that was close watch your
fingers when you're cutting always
the dressing so simple
mayonnaise good mayonnaise apple cider
vinegar a little bit of mustard in there
not much
pinch of salt two pinches of sugar
creamy i'm going for the creamy texture
of coleslaw
wet salad i like to call it yeah
that's perfect we have our slaw let's
move on to chili
low-tech cooking oh [ __ ] sorry i made
some chili
i made some chili actually i made some
chili in my grandfather's pan which i
believe this pan
is over 150 years old old cast iron
definitely adds to the flavor of
anything
trust me chili con carne very very
simple recipe it's nothing more than
crumbled cooked beef with the fat
drained off and to that all i added
was spices like chili cumin garlic
powder
salt a lot of water tomato paste
and you just keep adjusting until you
like what it tastes like
cook covered up with the water for a
good 15-20 minutes
take the top off and try to reduce it
and you have this beautiful
chili that goes on anything so it goes
in your mouth
[Music]
hot okay let's make a burger i'm gonna
start with beef
and make a patty by taking two pieces of
parchment paper
and smashing it then with my hand just
like
so
look at that it's a perfectly thin patty
this goes on the flat top just like that
put a little saltwater
put a little salt on it
people think i just eat hamburgers all
day long and then go to sleep
that's sort of half true i mean i also
stay very active i mean look at my ride
my bike
[Music]
[Applause]
i bike for fun but i also like my health
i consider my hamburger intake to be a
privilege not a right
one of my favorite chili burgers in
america is at a place called dukes in
monroe north carolina
by the way if you go to dukes and you go
get yourself a slobber all the way
do not talk on your cell phone dennis
will kick your ass right out of that
place i swear to god
hide the phone cheese on top
now the way they build the burger at
dukes they put the
chili on the bottom of the bun now very
important to toast your bun if you're
gonna put any kind of sauce on it
like this especially because it'll go
right through the damn bun so the first
thing they do is he basically dopes or
preps the bun
with a healthy dollop of chili on top of
that
he adds coleslaw and then on top of that
goes the patty
oh yeah oh god okay on top of that diced
onions
on the top of that it was the crown
[Laughter]
look at that thing that is beautiful
it has everything you want in it i mean
if you think about it's got a little bit
of
it's got a little bit of salad in it a
little bit of chili in it some cheese
some
raw onions got a little bit of
everything in it
oh my god
you get everything you get it's a
cheeseburger you get that beef
bite because of the chili not because of
the hamburger
that good spice ooh
fam eat the salad
the coleslaw north carolina
slaw burger with chili one of my
favorite chili inventions
i'll see you next time i'm gonna finish
this
you